A belief in God is among the most common
religious beliefs held by Americans.
Nine-in-ten Americans report believing in God,
or a universal spirit. However,
perspectives on God are incredibly
varied, and doubts about God's existence
are far more prevalent among the public
than typically thought. Thoughts about God
vary considerably by religious tradition
and three groups really stand out: white
evangelical Protestants, black
Protestants, and Mormons. In contrast,
Jewish Americans are far less certain in
their views of God. There's also a great
deal of uncertainty among the
non-religious. While 71% of atheists feel
completely certain God does not exist,
more than one quarter expressed some
amount of doubt. There are also stark
divides when it comes to age gender and
political affiliation. Young adults
expressed more doubt about God than
older Americans, and conservatives are
far more certain in their beliefs than
liberals. Despite these differences, when
it comes to religious belief, doubting may
be the one thing that unites believers
and non-believers.
How certain are you
that God exists? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.